hello everyone and welcome back to a
brand new episode of the witching hour
I am Perry Nemiroff and I'm sitting
across my co-host Hayley found it's
because we have some really cool people
in the studio today I think you guys
have heard this from me already I don't
know if everyone got your opinion on the
movie but I'm not sure it's a very big
fans of the upcoming movie ready or not
in the room and we have the team behind
the film here with us right now it is
radio silence would you guys mind
introducing yourselves and your roles
within the group briefly
yeah I'm Tyler Jillette I'm one of the
directors and I'm Chad vilela I'm the
executive producer on ready or not okay
so we've got a team that's been together
for a little while now so we want to go
back to the beginning I have some big
details on how you guys all met but just
so our listeners who don't know you guys
very well right now can kind of catch up
can you give us the the story of the
very beginning we started 10 years ago
and you the Chad met have been working
together a couple years 2000 internets
yep and then I worked with Tyler we were
new and we got to make some stuff and we
all started working together and kind of
continued that for another 3 or 4 yeah
yeah and then VHS happened yeah Brad
Miska reached out to us Bloody
Disgusting brought us into that friend
that anthology and that was the first
thing that I think we screened
theatrically at Sundance yeah yeah and
that was that was that was like the the
leveling up of what we were doing in the
digital space
we simply and we've continued to work
together ever since
what about falling into each of your
respective positions because I also know
you guys both direct but Samara was just
in the studio and she was telling me
that like one of you specifies in one
area of the filmmaking process and the
other does the other so how did you guys
all fall into your positions
I mean I think that's an evolution that
started when we first when we first
started working together you know we
were working with with the money that
was in our pockets and and we didn't
have you know we didn't have the time to
really hire a bunch of people and create
a big production so we were learning how
to do everything on our own and back
then there were there were four of us
and then five of us working on Final
Four yeah working on this on this this
wild sort of landscape of YouTube at the
time and so we learned how to do
everything I think over the course of
making what like four or five smaller
projects together I think that we all
had we all had specific interests going
into those projects but I think we all
sort of had specialties we kind of found
our niches within the process and as
we've evolved in the projects that we've
made have evolved I think that we've
we've all the collaboration has always
been the same but I think those
specialties have become a little bit
more defined and there's always been
enough overlap that we're able to call
[ __ ] on each other like if someone's
making for something that's not really
the best idea we've there's a shorthand
now where it's like come on so can you
guys each name that one of the others
specifies in that you say to yourself
like thank god he's good at that I would
never want to do it yeah I mean Matt
Matt when he sits down at the computer
to write it like the story comes out of
him in a way that I think is
intimidating and terrifying for most
people and that's just like you know
that's just my that's just my thing
isn't forever
communicating it's like you know like
we're in like rooms it's like a lot of
times like you like you're good at it
Chad my book I are good at doing that
[Music]
nonverbal communication Chad I don't
know I guess French horn and and I just
lay on it every now and then and just
whenever we're in the run of things I
like to give a nice little blast a
little more and make sure it's all how
does that play out practically when
you're on set shooting a scene like
where will what did we find you in that
day if you're shooting let's say one of
the action scenes or something like that
well Tyler is dealing with DP a lot I'm
dealing with the actors a lot Chad's
dealing with the other departments but
there's a lot of overlap there's a lot
of conversation it's never like go do
you it's like yeah you know I mean you
know it's a lot of work you've got
[ __ ] 20 people and behind not enough
yeah and I don't think it's it's not
like you know when a kid is denied
something from one parent they ask the
same thing from another and get a
different answer like you could come to
any of us and yeah the same question and
get the same answer because we've all we
are our whole our way of working is that
we create as much friction creative
friction as possible as early as
possible so that by the time we get to
set between us yeah between and between
us and with the riders and like working
on what you know what's it really about
like what are we trying to say with the
scene what's the blocking like
everything it is is so it's so planned
going into it that once we're on set
it's it's it's this really sort of
well-oiled machine that never goes as
planned but then when at least we're
prepared to dodge and duck is necessary
did anyone on ready or not try to play
the mom or dad game like they wanted
something to be a certain way and got a
no from what abuse I know the other I
don't know I don't know
I think the odd challenge ready or not
is that there were scenes there were
some scenes where there were nine nine
characters with speaking roles so there
are often times there it was like you
know I'd be talking to Henry and you'd
be talking to Adam or you know that
there was a little bit of a little bit
of group communication happening just
because for the sake of time and you
know the need to like make our days and
get all the coverage there was a little
bit that but I don't I don't think there
was everything I think we've ever had
like now because because that we make it
really clear I think one of the things
that happens when weren't around like I
said what theis it's like we make it
really clear like when you get an answer
like the conversation can happen then
you know it's always a conversation so
it even if you someone did do that it
just feel like a continuation of the
same conversation if that makes sense so
it wouldn't even and everybody would
know that that person tried to do that
like almost immediately like you know I
know we were doing budget stuff that
happened a little bit you gotta talk to
them about get this budget down like no
we need this like that type of thing
happened but it was never an issue and
we were able to like address it in a way
where we were able to get exactly what
we wanted creatively out of it
where does this project come up and come
along because we hear a lot from
filmmakers in here you know like keep it
contained keep it small you can get your
movie made this is like a very ambitious
like you said nein speaking actors and
one scene calls for a very large mansion
and a lot of really stunning you know
sort of imagery on film so where did
that go like yeah we can we can make
this happen being over like I mean we
and that's something we've been done
from forever when we had no money just
shooting stuff you know like a block
away from here actually would just be
like well let's make you feel like this
and then we'll do it for this and on
this movie I mean our initial budgets on
this movie came in at almost three times
the budget yeah and you know searchlight
who was wonderful to work with and like
just could not have asked for a better
partner in this but you know they wanted
to make it for a certain number and so
they kept working with us on it to get
it there and one of the things that was
so cool about that is none of the none
of the movie ever got sacrificed in it
like you know we didn't have as many
scenes and stuff but at the end of the
day you're like those probably were all
been cut anyways like it just made us
refine refine refine until it was like
how do we make this movie feel like more
than it is when also you could look at
it and be like well they earn a house
for most of the movie you know but our
goal
shooting was to never make it feel like
this is a house movie well I think the
production design is really understand
rich and beautiful and it goes a long
way like it's also very big and then and
then of course I mean it's so much of
that to is just how its photographed
yeah and having a having a DP that
really understood that I needed to have
this the cinematic look and feel
traditional and feel really naturalistic
and then kind of devolve you know sort
of start classic and a little more
steady and then fall apart as we as we
are going deeper and deeper into Grace's
nightmare it gets a little bit more
handheld and so yeah I think it was I
mean look it was it's such a testament
the the look of the movie and the fact
that it looks like it costs more than it
does is really a testament to the
departments and the work that they did
and bringing the this elevated thing to
life what was it like between Devil's
Due and this because I know you guys
jump from short to feature short feature
again but Devils do what did they come
out in 2014 as far as I can remember it
was fairly successful at the box office
so was there anything weekend early
January what was the response
immediately after that came out and why
did it take this amount of time in order
for ready or not to get greenlight it's
a good question I mean it's it's funny
it's what's something they like we
talked about lock because that was due
tonight do great in like you know break
down a bunch of doors for us but it was
a wonderful learning experience and and
and a great a great just overall I mean
I don't think any of the stuff we've
done since then we could have done had
we not done that but we were not allowed
to go make another studio movie after
that maybe just with actually called us
he'd been basically on our back since
DHS being like let's make something else
together and and then so after that we
were kind of like okay we got to go like
wash off this this thing and just try
something totally different which is
weird because we actually went back to
work with the exact same people we
worked with before
and so we just made southbound in the
interim and then right after southbound
we got attached already or not but the
process from getting ready or not to
screen was three years three and a half
years yeah and I think the big lesson
that we learned right after Devils do
was make something that you're really
passionate about me that you want to
watch you know like we're super proud of
that movie and we knew there that
found-footage you know we did it with
VHS we did it in some of our shorts it
like found footage isn't always the most
well received theatrically especially
around town like finding the next job or
finding somebody else to believe in you
that way but in a way it's harder than
making a lot of movies because you don't
have things to use like close-ups or
score or anything else that would so we
were able to learn off of that and again
just getting into the whole southbound
of it all we wanted to work with people
that we love and adore and like going
back to the whole VHS family and working
with everybody again on a story that we
are all so intimately involved with from
initial concept to writing to scripts to
shooting and even like down to the edits
when we're helping each other out on
edits like that sense of family is like
that that's that that was a lot of fun
for us and and we very luckily found it
again with the script for ready or not
with the producers trip Vincent Jamey
Vanderbilt the writers guy Busic and
Ryan Murphy Ryan Christopher Murphy like
a good time with with people that you
know whose opinions you respect and
making something that you're absolutely
adamant that you want to watch was one
of the bigger lessons of that experience
just to give our viewers a little
background here we're also we're talking
about a movie that and you guys can
correct us box office mojo is wrong but
a reported by a production budget of
seven million dollars that opened up a
little north of eight million so and
eventually 36 million almost 37 million
worldwide that doesn't sound like a bus
to me doing like February of 2014 to
like be the one out there to die
things have changed a little bit and I
think I think one of the reasons I think
looking at that now we movies movies
that are made at that budget are I think
I received a little differently now I
think that the the appetite for them has
changed a little bit and I think that
there's I think that the audience wants
to kind of vote for an underdog movie a
little bit more and there was something
weird that happened with Devil's Due
where you know we were shooting we were
shooting a movie that had this really
homegrown home video intimate feel to it
that was being released by big Fox so
there was I think there was a there was
a perception there was there was a sort
of perception gap between what audiences
expected the movie to be and ultimately
what it was and a lot of that just comes
down to the format I think when you see
that you know the fanfare in front of a
movie there's an expectation of what of
what the experience have it's gonna be
and we we we are proud of the movie that
we made and we think that being really
hard on yeah that was one of the things
that I think is so interesting is that
it gets dropped into just like
found-footage trash can and we're like
man we were like we're making a studio
movie using iPhones and like push you
know we're like we are pushing
boundaries every way that we can and
then you kind of sit back and you like
oh no one cares yeah I think when when
an indie film gets made that way that's
part of his channel I think there's a
conversation about about the making of
it that happens before anyone sees it
that I think gives gives the audience
additional context to enjoy the film in
a different way and with the with a you
know wide release like Devils do it just
it has to land and sort of stand stand
on its own and that's I don't know it
was an interesting experience this
conversation is making me think of a
variety article I was just reading a
little while ago and I'm curious having
worked with big Fox on Devil's Due and
now Fox Searchlight on ready or not
especially with the Disney merger that
happened earlier this year did you guys
notice any difference on your end as far
as the distribution process in the
marketing process went none I mean none
like if there was any weed in there
and we've been thrilled with the
marketing for this movie it's been by
far the best experience we've had with
that and and also in the making of I
mean everybody knew that does anything
was coming during it and it's like
nothing got watered down if anything
they were like no for more go for more
like there was there was zero what you
might expect from some like gigantic
merger between keep our jobs and keep
don't you think it was more like wow
okay this thing is happening we have to
set a precedent for the kind of crazy
movies that we that we hope to make and
and if we can set that precedent early
then you know hopefully you know the
things that follow can fall somewhere in
this like wide guardrail I have my
fingers crossed for that yes as well as
well the marketing was really strong
like that trailer dropped in it just
instantly I feel like everybody I knew
is like seeing that like I want to see
that movie
I agree that they knocked that out of
the park I want to jump back to
something you mentioned which is filming
in three houses how do you create
geography in your film I mean we we
wanted to shoot practically because one
of the things that we one of the things
that we found important and that we
think is important in most thrillers
where someone's on the run and you're
following them through a space is that
you're able to carry the characters from
one space to the other when you start
cutting around corners
it starts the audience yeah even
subconsciously is aware that there's a
fabrication of space happening and for
us you know it was um
we we and we I mean it was there are a
lot of bizarre geography cheats in the
movie we actually are intentionally
let's not make it too you know right and
early on be more literal early on with
the geography so that the audience has
more of a sense of where they are and
then as again the movie kind of falls
apart we we abandon the logic of the
house a little bit and grace is feeling
more lost in the audience is feeling
more lost but I mean and we wanted our
designer he rented out the
Prince of the houses and when we were
blocking the scenes we were conscious to
create some continuity between those
spaces it was more of having continuity
between spaces in these different scenes
but never being like here is the whole
house with you there's never a wide shot
of the house you never see the roof you
never see the edges like and it was all
this kind of you know we had that take
that version and we're like that doesn't
work it actually makes it feel smaller
but I can't get out of my head the
fountain in the boys actually pick up on
that because I would have noticed six
episode 6 episode of this season and
myself also heavily featured and when my
sister had her baby that's where I stop
if I have the nerve I will circle back
I should just be the expert in the Billy
Madison fountain on the big screen we're
also big big fans of smart waving and we
are so so happy that she scored the lead
role in this film so so what why did you
guys go out and offer the part to hurt I
assume it has something to do with the
babysitter um you know it actually has
more to do it definitely she was great
in that but it actually has a lot to do
with certs I loved her and they really
were like you guys really should look at
her because they worked with her on
three billboards and I didn't make the
connection and then okay cool and then
we met her and we were like oh [ __ ] like
she has she has that like
vulnerability that like creates an
empathy but she's also very strong and
very like her foundation is very firm
and so like there's this amazing mix
that is hard to find you know where
you're like oh [ __ ] I really root for is
the underdog but also I believe that she
can kick ass and I mean once you meet
her you're like oh [ __ ]
please oh god I hope she takes the role
I mean we were like we went from like
sure let's meet her and see what this is
all about and I'm like oh she gotta have
her before they suggested her to you I'm
just curious what did you picture for
that role is it something drastically
different than what she brought to it I
mean honestly I think she brought such a
specific thing I don't really like the
tattoos you know those are some artists
tattoos you see like little chili pepper
on her hands and stuff like that is like
this nice rebellious nature against you
know the zubur
rich family and she just embodied it
like right from the start
yeah just find out that she didn't the
way that I think she approaches the
collaboration is well which was a really
really natural fit for us like she just
just joined the team she joined the team
immediately and she was not
self-conscious about about pitching her
ideas and pitching her versions of how a
scene or we should be blocked or take
place and and then just the fearlessness
of having to do so much of what that
role requires physically I mean that's
the amount of action and the amount of
stunt work that she that she was like no
no I got this I want to I want to try
this and and then just like you know
pulls it off we you know we're all dudes
and are like forties almost 40s you know
and so we relied on her a lot to like
bring an honesty to the character
because we're like we can't tell you
what that is we don't know what that is
do you and I mean so we relied on her a
lot to be like well this is how this
works you know so it was like it was a
really great collaboration can I put her
on the spot really quickly we did a
Collider spotlight piece on her and one
of my favorite new questions to asks I
am obsessed with looking on someone's
IMDB page and in particular the trivia
section cuz you just find the weird
ratcheting section and she is next to
nothing weird so I told her to pitch
three things and she gave me three good
things but then she was very
disappointed in herself after that she
couldn't think of any like weird habits
or anything so from your perspective as
the folks who worked on this movie with
her what is something you would add to
her IMDB trivia page I think I got she
adopted a dog which obviously pleases us
both if she could only get one food for
the rest of her life it would be cheese
and then the first one
oh it's escaping me I can find it out
this does sound pretty relatable I mean
she might she might kill us but I know
that I know that she was so exhausted
after one of our shoots that she fell
asleep with her hand in a pizza that's
funny because the other one I had here
is that she's an insomniac I'm an
insomniac and I have to watch cartoons
to fall asleep like Bob's Burgers and
Rick and Morty are do a film is
exhausting the dog and cheese I will
throw this back in the same direction
and ask about casting Adam Brody because
I did not watch The OC I know him as the
creepy guy from Jennifer's Body knows
like oh [ __ ] he's awesome like he got me
in this movie how did you land on him
for that role honestly that was another
that was another searchlight pitch to
they they search like they know what
they're doing over there
yeah and they we we did a call with them
I think we were scouting we were driving
through like rural was in to FaceTime
drive and talking with him and his his
take on the character on the what's on
the page and what Adam did with it there
there is there's a real evolution in
between those two things and I think
what he brought to that character was
something that was so unexpected for us
and and elevates the emotionality of the
night away that I don't I don't think
that I don't think was there
to begin with Daniel on the page was
this kind of jokester and Adam more
funny less dark
yeah and Adam brought this kind of
desperation to it that that we think
because there's so much of him you know
early in the movie it it gives the it
gives the audience in the movie
permission to actually hit some really
dark genuine dramatic moments and and
he's he's that throughout the movie he
kind of grounds the insanity of the
family in a way that that just pulls us
back into reality when we needed you
know never like just when you think the
movies gonna go off the rails you have a
scene with him and he brings he brings
you back to the kind of tragedy of this
whole of this whole night and I mean
he's incredible to work with yes [ __ ]
exceeded all our expectations and you
know like I mean I was a huge OC fan I
watched all of it and I remember when
they pitched it and I'm never told him
this so hopefully doesn't get mad but I
was like huh interesting you know and
then we talked to you on that call and I
always remember this moment at the end
he said do you guys remember this that
he goes it was very you know these are
always like you kind of testing each
other out and it's always kind of
surface I got like this everybody talks
about stuff but then at the end he was
like well you know guys good luck with
everything
I mean or not but he was like yeah and
it was like this is gonna be exciting
whether it's him or someone else in this
ensemble because you do have a pretty
epic ensemble here who was kind of I
guess like the family MVP to you or
maybe someone that went so above and
beyond what you originally envisioned
for that role I'd say and returning yeah
yeah he brought the role of Tony to life
in like such an incredible way like he
even went out and found a Latin
professor to help him with the Latin for
the black mass for the the ritual scene
and he went above and beyond every
single day I think that's true for
everybody yeah I really do like I mean
Nicky is
right Nikki is Hamelin like we all
wanted it to be that we didn't I mean
even when we were shooting we were like
okay we got to get safe takes you know
like what's in the movie return the most
of daily right what we want it but you
know you're shooting and you're like is
this gonna [ __ ] work cuz like like
Samara is so grounded and Adam Brody is
so grounded and then you have like Nikki
being like so big and we're like in our
in our version of the movie that's what
we want but you know you you never know
what's gonna work so we would get like
let's just do it like way way more
grounded we didn't use any really any of
that we went for like just cuz she
killed it but but like she did I mean
everybody doing this type of movie for
the first time in her career was just
like oh this this is gonna be fun and it
is emotional scene with Mark yeah be
kind of is like the Keystone to the
whole movie like oh this is really what
the whole thing is about just mom and
son having this [ __ ] conversation
here like this that feeling is like
inevitability when you've made when
you've made a project and you realize
that you can't you cannot imagine anyone
other than who is in the role in the
role that there's this this alchemy that
kind of takes shape over the process and
then over the you know the post the post
process I mean John Ralston is that is a
lot of that is just I mean a lot of it
is hard work and it's writing and it's
directing and it's all of this but a lot
of it too is just it's just like and and
sometimes it the you know the wind blows
your way and you you get this incredible
group of people and and they're all
still friends now which is like not
something like that's one of the things
I think we're most proud about is like
they're all on text chains together they
all hang out and kick it you know
they'll see each other we gave them a
bonding experience even if it's against
us but like their Instagram post and
everything they're all together having a
good time oh this is this is pretty cool
how how did you find directing that many
actors at a time what is like what's
your practical advice to get that right
it was it was prep and it was you know
it's the script is so good and it's
honestly I think a lot of it is and the
scripts really well-written so there
weren't a lot of like I don't
standed kinda like we've worked on
things before where actors are like I
literally don't understand what the [ __ ]
this scene is about there was none of
that you know this was like everybody
understood everybody got it but I think
one of the things that really worked for
us and hopefully though the cast is that
everybody had their character that was
like this box but then we never were
like you need to be in this box it was
like do what you want to do that will
make this feel right to you make it make
you feel authentic like we're talked
about earlier with Adam like his
character was slightly different on the
page but what he did with it felt very
grounded and very authentic and I think
that's true for everybody across the
board it was never like say it this way
do that thing you know it was more like
alright everybody find their way through
this and we're gonna all be here
together holding hands and make sure we
get there did you guys enjoy working on
you know focus story the other challenge
is just walking yeah you know nine
people and and one of the things that we
really wanted to do cuz the the easy way
to shoot a scene like that is to just
have everyone stand stationary and cover
it out like you would you know like you
would imagine you do if you had as
little time as we had but for us it was
really about creating creating a lot of
motion and movement and I think once
once the the actors were up and we're
moving in this space I actually think it
sort of helps the energy of their
characters and who they are and you you
start getting a lot of really fun
interesting visual surprises and also
just kind of performance surprises that
you maybe wouldn't normally have it's
not it's not this wooden stilted you
know shot reversed shot thing now
there's suddenly a bit of movement and
characters are crossing frame and people
are sitting down with each other and
standing up and there's you know there's
a real sense of evolution in those
scenes and with more characters there's
more of that so it's it's um the scenes
become more dynamic in a way that we
thought just not only fit the kind of
weird ensemble of the family but it also
helped us use the [ __ ] house right as
those spaces are so big it helped us see
more of that story wise because
everybody has
a specific point of view so everybody
got to embody something very clean about
how the night's gonna go or whether
they're you know my Christians on one
end is Fitch because this for real you
know and then you have Nikki on the
other end is an helene you can't even
buy everything in that cast I do it
again to answer your question in your
downtime did you guys ever play board
games card games I think Christian or
mark brought a game involved words
guessing words we never quite understood
we play for like two minutes if you like
but I know they all played that the
whole time the green room on set was
always the place that I wanted to spend
more it was like you cross it and you'd
hear a bunch of laughter and they'd be
[ __ ] around doing something but you
were on your way to like have a really
difficult conversation yeah it was there
was always some kind of weird game
happening I have so many spoiler
questions about just like the whole
premise and how it evolves before we
kind of you know tip the scale over do
we want to ask our final like our last
two regular questions this time you go
first you pick one okay surprise me yes
we usually end the episode with this
because we find it sends people out
really happy but we'll do it here yeah
I've got my dog Hank I mean he's kind of
a radio silence dog yes he was there for
the post on Devil's Due at that
editorial he was there for all the post
on one ready or not he's yeah he's kind
of amusing what kind of dog is Hank he's
a wheaten terrier my sister has a
wheaten terrier they're the sweetest
thing so eat and smile is a real thing
he's a
the kind mm-hmm got a cat mini she's my
favorite yeah I do not have a pet at
this time but I I will be looking to
adopt sometime very soon
Marley for 13 and a half or so and he
was a three and a half pound bear yeah
Yorkie
but he was awesome we use everything -
yeah you actually got a teacup most
people buy a teacup and then it turns
out to be eight to ten oh I didn't know
it's just like you supposed to grow so
the second question we always like to
end on is doesn't matter if it's TV
movies a book anything at all
what is something in the horror genre
that you have watched recently whether
it's something new something old that
you want our viewers to know about and
check out I know mine
it's a French show called black spot I
think is don't blush in French it's on
Netflix right now I watched a first
season on Amazon about a year and a half
ago two years ago and it's it's a small
town in this remote French forest and
it's basically a drama about small-town
politics a police force but in the woods
there's this pagan supernatural force
that's that's happening that the town is
trying to keep a secret and I've just
been obsessed with it because it touches
things like Twin Peaks because it's
about a missing girl and the first thing
but then it combines you know it's just
it goes there when other shows did not
go there like the mysticism of season
one of true detective and then it just
then it will explain it like you know
patterns of birds flying in the sky and
then then seeing this pagan ritual take
place towards the end of the first
season and and season two it was a lot
of fun and I'm still working through
season to you right now so old I feel
like this is good content to download
for our flight to Washington I don't
think that's a very long flight
two and a half hours you get five hours
back and forth I am I am sure where I
can pinch an entire season or something
I just added that to my queue so I'm
very excited yes it's fine
nice I I'm in the middle of like a deep
dive podcast on Halloween that Amy
Nicholson is doing and he hasn't heard
it it might be from like a year or two
ago it's after the new Halloween I don't
know why I just found it though it's so
good I'm like six episodes in maybe and
it is like everything you ever wanted to
know about Halloween I'm loving it I'm
rereading a good book called Slade house
by David Mitchell that is an awesome
weird take on a haunted house and it
sort of reads like an anthology it's the
same house over I think it's it's 50 or
60 years and every nine or so years the
house invites a new guest into it and
and they go through this sort of crazy
psychological experience that ultimately
ends with their soul being taken rule
but you live with the character through
I call the terror of that and it's a
really great weird I like the sound of
that
yep and how much running I have ahead of
me I already have the audio book but not
as long as my flight but I'll be running
for hours so I'll take care of that one
I like that we just use our talent for
recommendation what are you listening to
hears about this all the time it has
nothing to do with genre but I have
recently and very lately become obsessed
with dad rota for know the podcast where
like the the host his father wrote a
porno and they basically read it through
chapter by chapter but that is that's
basically like morning run and night now
I have to listen to an episode
they've been doing it for seasons and
seasons and now they have they have a
live show that tours the world and in
hbo's produced a great podcast wonderful
I thought you were gonna say Downton
Abbey actually Oh God Abbey to start
prepping for for TIFF and for North
Bears but I'm gonna get back to it so I
did really like it me gosh I don't like
when the pressures on me we watched so
much I forget about guys thank you so
much for your time today I'm gonna say
it again
even though if you're still with us you
should have seen ready or not by now but
just in case in case you want to tell
everybody you know it hits theaters
August 21st
check it out don't miss it thank you
again for your time is there anywhere
our viewers can find you on social media
Instagram Twitter or anything like that
yeah are the radio silence is high radio
silence a chai radio silence on all of
the all the socials which view what few
[Music]
other socials are Tyler Juliet Matt
Benelli open chat vilela yep come say hi
all right send us into sequel pictures
yes
Hayley where can everyone find you on
the Instagram Twitter all that good
stuff you can find me on Twitter at
Haley foutch and Instagram and haystack
mcgroove II and I am at PNM Ralph on
Twitter and Instagram thank you again
for listening or watching this episode
you have officially survived the
witching hour